O
WATCH.
THANK YOU.
STAY SAFE.
>> I HOPE TO SEE AGAIN.
HOME.
I HOPE THAT ALL OF US WILL STAY
ALIVE.
I REALLY HOPE THAT MY HUSBAND
COMES BACK HOME.
>> Laura: THE WOMAN YOU JUST
SAW WAS A UKRAINIAN YOUTUBE.
LIKE MANY PEOPLE IN KYIV, SHE
HUNKERED DOWN IN A BOMBSHELL
TERM IN THE CITY'S STRICT CURFEW
GOES INTO EFFECT.
ELAINA JOINS ME LIFE FROM THAT
BOMB SHELTER.
ALAYNA, WE JUST HEARD YOU TALK
ABOUT YOUR HUSBAND.
I KNOW HE'S OUT THERE AND I KNOW
HE'S PREPARED TO FIGHT.
ONE WAS THE LAST TIME YOU TALKED
TO HIM.
>> IN THE EVENING.
RIGHT NOW IT'S EARLY MORNING.
WE TALKED BEFORE THE NIGHT.
HE SAID THAT HE WAS FIGHTING.
>> Laura: YOU ARE CLUTCHING
YOUR BABY IN YOUR ARMS.
I KNOW THERE'S SO MANY CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY IN THE UNDERGROUND,
IN THE METRO AREA THAT'S BEING
USED AS AN EXTENSIVE BOMB
SHELTER FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UKRAINIANS.
BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT FOOD AND
MILK AND SUPPLIES, MEDICINES.
DO YOU HAVE THOSE BASIC
NECESSITIES TONIGHT, AS YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THIS IS
GOING TO GO ON?
>> FOR TODAY, FOR TOMORROW WE
HAVE ENOUGH.
WE HAVE ENOUGH.
MAYBE EVEN FOR A WEEK WE HAVE
ENOUGH.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE HAVE MORE.
>> Laura: THOSE UKRAINIANS
TONIGHT, THOSE UKRAINIANS
TONIGHT WHO HAVE NOT HAD THE
CHANCE TO REACH THEIR LOVED
ONES, THEIR BROTHERS OR THEIR
OWN GOALS, THEIR HUSBANDS, IT'S
UNSPEAKABLY DIFFICULT.
NOT KNOWING WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
HOW HARD HAS THAT BEEN FOR YOUR
FRIENDS AND OTHERS WHO'VE
PERHAPS LOST TOUCH WITH THOSE
WHO REMAINED TO FIGHT?
>> I THINK WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN NEXT.
SOMEBODY ALREADY TOLD TO YOU,
YES, THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
ARRANGE A MASSACRE HERE.
SO I THINK WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH FOOD
JUST FOR ONE WEEK.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE WATER
ENOUGH FOR ONE WEEK.
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE KNOW THAT PUTIN WILL NOT
CONQUER UKRAINE.
IF HE CONQUERS UKRAINE, HE WON'T
BE ABLE TO HOLD IT.
THIS IS WHY HE'S GOING TO JUST
KILL THE MOST OF THE POPULATION
WHO IS LEFT WHO DIDN'T RUN AWAY.
THIS IS HOW HE'S GOING TO HOLD
UKRAINE.
HE IS GOING TO MAKE HERE A
GENOCIDE, A MASSACRE.
WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: DID YOU TRY TO LEAVE
UKRAINE?
DID YOU MAKE A DECISION THAT YOU
WERE NOT GOING TO?
>> I HAD ENOUGH FUEL.
WE HAD A CAR.
WITH FUEL AND EVERYTHING BUT WE
DECIDED TO STAY BECAUSE IF WE
RUN AWAY FROM OUR HOME, YOU WILL
NOT COME INSIDE OF US AND
PROTECT OUR HOME, RIGHT?
FIRST OF ALL, OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT OUR HOME.
IF I LEFT AND LEFT ALL THESE
PEOPLE BEHIND ME HERE IN THE
CITY, ALL THESE WOMEN, CHILDREN
AND MEN BECAUSE FOR ME, THE LIFE
OF MEN AND WOMEN IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT.
I FEEL PITY FOR EVERYONE.
WOMEN AND MEN.
IF I LEFT ALL OF THEM HERE AND
DID NOT EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
SAVE THEM, I JUST WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO LIVE WITH IT ANYWHERE.
IN THE U.S., IN FRANCE.
IT'S GOOD TO TRAVEL FOR
VACATION.
BUT NOT JUST RUN AWAY AND KNOW
THAT YOU LEFT BEHIND YOUR PEOPLE
TO DIE.
I WOULDN'T SURVIVE WITH IT.
I WOULDN'T WANT MY CHILDREN TO
LIVE WITH IT.
I STAY I DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
I STILL HOPE THAT WE WILL BE
SAVED.
THAT WE WILL WIN.
WE NEED HELP.
WE REALLY NEED URGENT HELP.
NO FLY ZONE.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IF YOU GUYS ARE AFRAID TO MAKE
PUTIN ANGRY AND PROVOKE HIM, YOU
SEE UKRAINIANS WERE NOT
PROVOKING ANYONE.
HE JUST ATTACKED.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THIS
SITUATION WAS NEEDLESSLY
PROVOKED, THAT PUTIN WAS
PROVOKED BY DESIRE FOR NATO
EXPANSION?
OR SOME TYPE OF FAILED
LEADERSHIP ALONG THE LINE?
>> NO.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
WE WERE NOT PROVOKING PUTIN.
IT WAS NOT PROVOKED.
IT WAS JUST -- HE JUST DOESN'T
WANT UKRAINE TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT COUNTRY.
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE UKRAINIAN
NATION EXISTS.
HE CLEARLY SAID.
IF WE SAY OKAY WE ARE NOT
UKRAINIANS, WILL BE RUSSIANS,
ONLY IN THIS.
HE IS NOT PROVOKED.
IT'S NOT A CONVERSATION.
IT'S NOT A NEGOTIATION.
IT'S JUST, I WANT YOU TO OBEY.
I WANT YOU TO BE UNDER MY
CONTROL.
AND IF YOU ARE NOT UNDER MY
CONTROL, I WILL KILL YOU.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW, WE ARE ALL
PRAYING FOR YOU AND WE ARE
PRAYING FOR THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
AND YOUR CHILDREN.
>> THANK YOU.
PRAYERS ARE NOT ENOUGH BUT
THANK YOU.
>> Laura: YOU NEED SUPPLIES
AND YOU NEED AMMUNITION.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE.
>> IF I HAVE AMMUNITION.
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE A
NO-FLY ZONE.
AND A GUN IN